En el video anterior hablamos del equilibrio
mecánico y de la primera condición de equilibrio.
Recordemos, entonces, que el equilibrio mecánico
ocurre cuando la suma de todas las fuerzas
externas que actúan sobre un cuerpo es igual
a cero, y la primera condición de equilibrio
dice que: un cuerpo se encuentra en equilibrio de
traslación cuando la suma vectorial de todas las
fuerzas externas que actúan sobre él es nula, la
suma vectorial de todas las fuerzas externas es
igual a cero. Como ejemplo vimos una lámpara que
cuelga del techo, en donde la fuerza de gravedad
que tira de ella hacia abajo es compensada por
la fuerza de tensión del cable que sujeta a la
lámpara al techo. Pero la primera condición no es
suficiente para definir el equilibrio de cualquier
cuerpo, también tiene que considerarse la segunda
condición que es el equilibrio rotacional,
ya que dos fuerzas en direcciones opuestas, no
necesariamente de la misma magnitud y que no estén
en la misma línea de acción -en un momento
veremos a qué se refiere línea de acción-,
generarán un desequilibrio en el cuerpo. En el
cuerpo de la lámpara imaginemos que aplicamos dos
fuerzas opuestas, una a cada lado de la lámpara;
ambas fuerzas están en el plano horizontal pero no
están sobre la misma línea de acción. La línea
de acción es la distancia del eje de rotación,
y lo que van a provocar es que la lámpara comience
a rotar, generando un desequilibrio. La segunda
condición es el equilibrio de rotación, y dice:
la suma vectorial de los momentos de fuerza
externos debe ser igual a cero, de no ser así
el cuerpo experimenta rotación alrededor de un
eje. Un momento de fuerza o torca es una medida
de la fuerza que puede hacer que un objeto gire
alrededor de un eje. Así como en la cinemática
lineal la fuerza puede hacer que un objeto
acelere, la torca es lo que provoca que un objeto
aumente su aceleración angular. Sin duda ya has
tenido una intuición de lo que es un momento
de fuerza o torca cada que abres una puerta:
cuando lo haces, empujas la puerta por el lado más
alejado de las bisagras, el picaporte o el punto
donde la empujas para abrirla es el punto donde se
aplica la fuerza. La distancia de este punto a las
bisagras que mantienen la puerta sujeta a la pared
se llama brazo del momento y el lugar donde están
las bisagras es el punto de rotación. Y quizá
te preguntes ¿cómo se calcula la torca? Bueno,
la torca es un vector, y la magnitud τ para una
torca producida por una fuerza dada F es el radio,
o lo que mide el brazo de momento, por el seno
del ángulo de rotación θ. Y para calcular la
dirección del vector de momento, o torca, usamos
la convención de la regla de la mano derecha:
si enrollas la mano alrededor del eje de rotación,
con los dedos apuntando en la dirección de la
fuerza, entonces el vector de la torca apunta
en la dirección del pulgar. Ahora que ya tenemos
en mente qué es la torca, regresemos a nuestra
segunda condición de equilibrio. Veamos algunos
ejemplos de equilibrio de rotación en el que la
suma vectorial de las torcas externas es igual
a 0. Retomando el ejemplo de la puerta, cuando
empujas una puerta cerrada con el seguro puesto
estás aplicando una torca estática a la puerta,
ya que ésta no gira sobre las bisagras a pesar de
la fuerza aplicada. Otra forma de pensar en
esto es que, al ver el diagrama de fuerzas,
si sumamos la fuerza en el picaporte de color
verde, que eres tú tratando de abrir la puerta,
y con la fuerza normal, que es la fuerza que
ejerce la puerta cerrada y que tiene la misma
magnitud pero sentido opuesto, vemos que la suma
vectorial de ambas fuerzas es igual a 0. La puerta
está en equilibrio rotacional. Otro ejemplo sería
el de un sube y baja con dos personas, una de cada
lado. Imagina a un niño pequeño que juega con su
hermano mayor. Ambos tienen distintas masas y,
entonces, para que estén en equilibrio rotacional,
es decir, para que la barra esté horizontal,
tienen que sentarse a distintas distancias
del punto de rotación para que las torcas,
en sentidos opuestos, se cancelen. Esto se ilustra
en el siguiente diagrama. El hermano menor,
que tiene menos masa y por lo tanto pesa menos,
ejerce una fuerza F₂ hacia abajo; el hermano mayor
tiene más masa y, por lo tanto, más peso ejerce
una fuerza F₁ hacia abajo. Si se sientan a la
misma distancia, la torca provocada por la fuerza
F₁ será mayor y en sentido de las manecillas del
reloj, y no habrá equilibrio rotacional, a menos
que el sube y baja choque con el suelo y ya no
habrá rotación. Pero si el hermano menor se sienta
a una distancia d₂ del centro del sube y baja,
y el hermano mayor a una distancia d₁, tales
que el producto F₁ • d₁ sea igual a F₂ • d₂,
entonces estarán aplicando dos torcas de
igual magnitud, pero en sentido contrario,
que se cancelarán de manera que el sube y baja
queda en equilibrio, es decir, que la F₁ • d₁ es
igual a la F₂ • d₂. Con estos ejemplos espero te
quede claro el concepto de equilibrio rotacional,
en el que la suma vectorial de los momentos
o torcas externas debe ser igual a 0,
y que es la segunda condición de
equilibrio para el equilibrio mecánico.